أبلغت مراكز مكافحة السموم أم
أن مكالماتهم ترتفع في أماكن
مثل ميسيسيبي وأوكلاهوما
لأن بعض الأمريكيين يحاولون استخدام
عقار مضاد للطفيليات
يسمى إيفرمكتين لعلاج
فيروس كورونا لمنع الإصابة
بفيروس كورونا ، فما الذي
ستقوله لشخص ما يفكر في تناوله
هذا الدواء
لا يفعل ذلك ، فلا يوجد دليل على
الإطلاق على أن ذلك يعمل
وقد يكون له سمية كما ذكرت للتو
مع الأشخاص الذين ذهبوا إلى
مراكز مكافحة السموم لأنهم
تناولوا الدواء بجرعة سخيفة
وانتهى بهم الأمر بالحصول على  مريض لا يوجد
دليل سريري يشير إلى أن هذا يعمل
لفترة طويلة حتى الآن كنت أقرأ
عن المعارضين البارزين للأقنعة
والمشككين في اللقاح يتحدثون عن مضيفي الراديو
والشخصيات الأخرى التي
تطمع وتحتضر ،
كان هناك عدد من هذه
التقارير في الأسبوع الماضي
ماذا  يمر بذهنك عندما ترى
قصصًا مثل تلك
جيدًا ، إنها مأساوية لأنك لا
تريد أن ترى أي شخص  بغض النظر
عن موقفهم أو أيديولوجيتهم ، فأنت
لا تريد أن ترى أي شخص يمرض أو يموت
خاصة كطبيب
وعالم أفعل كل شيء في حياتي
المهنية بأكملها لحماية صحة
الناس وإنقاذ الأرواح ، لذلك حتى لو كان لديهم
الآراء التي لا أتفق معها تمامًا ،
إنها مأساة حقًا أن أراهم يمرضون
ويموتون بشكل أساسي لأنهم
يضعون جانبًا ويتجنبون
مبادئ الصحة العامة التي
نتحدث عنها طوال الوقت